while I don't love lending credibility
to millennial stereotypes I do spend a
lot of my time texting actually I think
there are some days where I type more
words on whatsapp than I speak out loud
which is the terrifying thought now that
I've said it on that Telltale's mister
robot mobile game which is developed by
the studio behind oxen-free arrived last
week basically you pick up someone
else's phone and begin getting cryptic
texts and instructions of course since
it's based on a show about hacking
that's some of that in here but the
hacking you're asked to do is far closer
to social engineering and identity theft
than actual hacking you'll be trying to
get passwords by impersonating the IT
guy not writing lines of code the whole
game exists within a fictional phone
operating system and your contact list
is peppered with characters from the
show
it also takes place during the events of
season 1 so don't worry if you're not up
to date with season 2 you also really
only play this game when you have text
to reply to which arrives sporadically
throughout the day so it's not like
every other game where you engage in it
if and when you want to this isn't the
first game that's tried this unusual
format lifeline is another mobile game
that focuses on trading text messages
this time with an astronaut who's
crash-landed on a creepy alien moon okay
so I got the dude killed on the first
day and had to start again but on my
second try it all got surprisingly tense
and my instructions as to what he should
do next felt very very important to
ensure the little guy made it through
the story is branching and dense and
while both of these games cost a few
dollars it is surprisingly affecting to
have fake people hitting you up on your
phone all day asking for help and advice
the world of mr. robot is especially
perfect for it the characters in the
game are written so very closely to
their television counterparts with
similar speech mannerisms and the
respective abrasive and calculated
personalities that fit with what you'd
expect of Darlene and Elliot the text
you get in game read like messages from
actual people complete with melodramatic
caps and autocorrect mistakes and
although you can't reply with whatever
you want when you're selecting between
reply options you make typos and
like words as you go there's little
realistic touches make the darker sides
of the game which draw on invasion of
privacy identity theft and social
anarchie feel all the more immersive
they make receiving tax stressful and
deciding on how to engage with the
people contacting you a more complicated
because you actually start giving a [ __ ]
to have a game emulate and hijack a way
of communicating that's pretty
exclusively reserved for your friends
and real people in your real life
is confronting and a point I found it
hard to remember it was all a game I
found myself checking my phone
constantly and getting irrationally
anxious about the links I had to go to
to make progress at one point I had to
threaten to reveal illicit information
about a guy to his young son in order to
blackmail him into helping me other
occasions forced me to assume people's
identities and potentially put them in
danger to get what I needed I constantly
had one foot in the realm of wanting to
get my way via the comest and least
intrusive means possible and the other
in a place where I found myself making
big threats hurting families and putting
careers in jeopardy for someone who's
used to coasting through decision-making
in games choosing only Paragon options
that's a tall order I know you're
thinking I'm being silly because it's
not real but the writing in text
emulation mechanics suddenly make it
feel real sometimes too real and it's
uncomfortable and bizarre feeling that
is it certainly makes it worth forking
over a few dollars for the experience